a massive crack that's up to 50 feet
deep suddenly opened up in the ground in
Africa it's already 65 feet wide in some
places and growing the crack stretches
along Kenya's Great Rift Valley many
scientists believe it could end up
breaking Africa's continent apart Debora
patta is tracking developments from
Johannesburg South Africa
Deborah good morning good morning this
massive crack is similar to other
geological formations like the Rio
Grande Rift Valley in the US but here in
Africa
scientists are divided as to how it came
to be imagine waking up one morning to
find a massive crack running from your
home that's what happened to Elliott
injured goona forced to dismantle his
house by hand before it was lost to the
earth below he lives in my MA Hugh part
of the Great Rift Valley in Kenya a
region that has already provided a
treasure trove of some of the most
important archaeological finds in
history and this latest discovery is so
significant scientists predict it will
be the fault line along which history is
made once again as Africa splits into
two continents although that won't
happen for a very long time says
geologist Bayne Andrews fortunately this
does not occur instantly so it's going
where were many tens of millions of
years away from having two continents
the crack in Kenya sits along the 3700
mile long east african rift geologists
say that rift is growing larger as two
tectonic plates move away from each
other
as this movement continues over the next
50 million years a large chunk of the
continent will eventually split off
creating an island that will consist of
parts of several African nations
scientists for the most part agree that
the continent is splitting in two but
there is debate over exactly how this
most recent fracture was revealed
Andrews believes the earth did not
suddenly split in two but that it formed
over hundreds of thousands of years it
looks like it was probably something
that already existed and had been filled
with ash and other material and then it
was flushed out by
recent rainfall the rains have indeed
been heavy in Kenya over the past month
and some geologists believe this crack
formed during those torrential downpours
rather than over years of tectonic
action biana yeah that's a big debate
going on whether it happened overnight
or over thousands of years ever about
enjoy whatever the reason beyond it
ain't good ya know you don't want your
house to be in the middle that cracks
but you have 50 million years to plan
for the island right